So, what makes up this dark matter?
Well, that's one of the missions of the Large Hadron Collider.
The LHC near Geneva is a big tunnel of pipes and magnets, and detectors more than 100 meters underground.
It's about 27 kilometers in circumference.
27. So big, it takes a slice out of both France and Switzerland.
It's the most complicated, most complex device ever built I would say.
And what does it do? It collides protons.
Protons are part of the nucleus of an atom.
The LHC shoots huge numbers of these protons in two beams going in opposite directions around the LHC...
...and very close to the speed of light.
When we're going full blast, the beams are gonna collide 40 million times a second, roughly.
40 million times a second!
And we're gonna look at all the data that comes out.
Particles are streaming out.
These collisions should be of such force to replicate the energy density of a very young universe.
A trillionth of a second after the "Big Bang".
Dark matter particles were key ingredients of that very early, very hot, dense universe.
Those energies in that small space was enough that you can actually make dark matter make new things.
And so, particles were zooming around in that early universe, colliding off each other.
Particles that don't even exist today.